vaman bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous alors après 13 ans de combat
la justice a donc donné raison aux
anciens salariés de goodyear êtes vous
soulagé par le jugement rendu
soulagé c'est surtout dans la période
j'ai choisi mon dire un miracle parce
que quand on regarde un petit peu et
qu'on analyse ce qui est devenu droit du
travail pour les licenciements
économiques
les deux derniers gouvernements on met
tout en place une série de règles de loi
qui ont purement et simplement supprimé
le licenciement pour motif économique du
code du travail en faisant date au de
baguette magique le la chose suivante
c'est à dire que on a contesté nous le
motif économique au niveau du groupe et
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus possible il
faut il faut aller justifier le motif
économique ou pas au niveau de
l'entreprise et avec les montages
financiers que sont les multinationales
je reviendrai sur le cas de renault
après c'est très simple pour eux en
trois mois temps de démontrer que
l'usiné n'est plus viable puisque les
usines de production sont venues des
usines de façonnage et non plus des
endroits où on fabrique et on vendait
ont récupéré la plus value financière
entre le coût de production et le prix
de vente c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
totalement explosé le code du travail et
le jugement d'hier c'est quand même
quelque chose d'exceptionnel dans la
période
c'est quelque chose de fort et je pense
que c'est pas par hasard que tous les
médias du pouvoir nos complètement
passés à travers pour ne pas donner
cette information mais par contre mettre
vraiment l'accent sur la nécessité d
entreprise à devoir licencier après ces
pièces du coville or ça ne trompera
personne et surtout pas moi ni mon
avocat l'avocat des goodyear c'est que
cette crise du coup vidal a bon dos je
l'attendais tacle coville est quasiment
un virus du capital qui aujourd'hui est
utilisé partout pour dégraisser
alors que tous les plans qui arrive
successivement était d'ores et déjà dans
les placards il ya quand même quelque
chose à rajouter j'ai entendu la députée
la république en marche à choisy le roi
je sais pas si ces gens là ils ont des
problèmes de schizophrénie
mais comment on peut aller sur un site
de production pour dire aux gens là avec
vous alors que dans le même temps ce
gouvernement a participé à détricoter
comme personne le code du travail et ne
permet plus aux salariés justement de
faire ce que nous avons fait pendant
sept ans à savoir faire à valider les
plans sauvegarde
l'emploi parce qu'ils ne sont pas
justifiées mais surtout le groupe
renault et s'agite ya et il faut
vraiment faire très attention aux propos
le groupe renault n'est pas en
difficulté financière le groupe renault
a versé des dizaines de milliards de
dividendes aux actionnaires ces cinq
dernières années le groupe renault c'est
aussi la faire carrière carlos ghosn
avec un personnage qui gagnent des
fortunes par jour qui gagnent des
fortunes par mois et qui détend de
l'argent des salariés et si le japon ne
s'était pas occupé de lui aujourd'hui
c'est être ministre en france donc c'est
ça aujourd'hui la réalité la réalité
c'est que oui effectivement on a gagné à
amiens on a gagné parce que on a un
avocat qu'il est allé qui a pris quatre
ans pour la récupérer des pièces parce
que goodyear voulait pas les fournir et
aujourd'hui malheureusement ce genre de
jugement est devenu quasiment impossible
donc il va faire date et il faut
vraiment qu'il soit utilisé comme
tremplin dans toutes les réunions
actuelle dans les grands groupes qui
veulent menacés de licenciement pour
dire voilà ce qui vous attend si vous
nous licencier mais la problématique
elle est surtout liée au fait de la
résistance des gens dans les entreprises
quand j'entends un syndicats comme la
cfdt
choisy-le-roi chez renault qui dit on va
utiliser tous les moyens nécessaires
pour faire mon prono mais me font
doucement marrer ces gens là ils signent
tous il accompagne tout si aujourd'hui
en partie le code du travail est détruit
on peut dire un grand merci à monsieur
bergé qui aujourd'hui se félicite y
compris d'un plan de sauvegarde en
europe de plus de 700 milliards d'euros
pour la relance économique
on en a rien à nous ce que l'on
veut voir aujourd'hui c'est comment se
fait-il que ces grands groupes qui ont
fait des profits colossaux pendant des
années qui ont versé des dividendes et
piétiné les salariés parce qu'ils se
permettent d'annoncer des suppressions
d'emplois aussi massive est alors le
plus ignoble dans tout ça c'est qu'il
n'y aura pas de licenciements secs nous
dit on on se fout de notre gueule
on se fout de notre gueule les gens vont
être virés points l'entreprise est
fermée points
la seule et l'unique bataille qui doit
être mené
c'est celle de l'emploi dans les
entreprises il faut que les camarades
les salariés menacés se disent une chose
il faut qu'il lutte
il faut qu'ils l'utilisent faut qu'il
démontre que cette entreprise renault
n'a pas plus de difficultés que goodyear
en avait voilà c'est une
nation temps là où c'est dramatique
c'est que c'est l'état qui vient dire
oui il ya nécessité vous comprenez c'est
compliqué et le confinement sa
durée de deux mois ça peut durer deux
ans mais merci beaucoup michael mann
d'avoir réellement nés sur notre antenne
il nous reste vraiment très très peu
trop calme était sandouville viennent
gagner pour pas redémarrer l'usiné que
la justice donne raison
on les insulte de tous les noms et on
oublie de dire juste que les parcs
étaient pleins de voiture et qu'on
voulait se payer la peau de la cgt de
sandouville et ça c'est scandaleux donc
renault n'a pas difficultés financières
pas plus que tous les autres et je vous
invite tous les camarades à se battait à
lutter il faut faire attention à nos
propos parce que ces entreprises là
n'ont pas de difficultés financières et
que ce pouvoir va les aider à licencier
c'est ça la réalité
merci beaucoup mais qu'elle va même
d'avoir réagi sur notre antenne je
rappelle que vous êtes excellent leader
cgt de goodyear